- [Narrator] Hello, everyone.
Today, we are going to be talking about
Earth's place in space.
So for as long as there have been humans,
we've been looking up at the stars,
and wondering about our
place in the universe.
Our understanding about
this has improved over time,
and we have developed models
that can help us understand
something as vast as space.
Now, models are just a way of
representing a system of ideas
that help us identify and
understand patterns that we see.
Models are a tool that can explain,
and predict what we see in
the world and space around us.
And as we gain new information,
we can update our models.
So what kind of model might we construct
about how Earth interacts with
other bodies in the universe?
To begin with, every day,
we can see the sun rise in
the east, and set in the west,
and other objects in the sky
follow a similar pattern.
It was logical then for early models
to consider the Earth
as a stationary object,
around which all of the universe revolves.
This is called a geocentric model,
geo for Earth, and centric for center.
And this geocentric model was quite good
at explaining a lot of the
things that we see in the sky,
like the apparent motion
of the sun and the stars.
But there were issues with
this geocentric model.
For example, the motions of
other planets in the sky.
A planet like Jupiter might
sometimes move backwards
in the opposite direction,
which isn't really very well explained
by this geocentric model.
Now, when a model doesn't match
our observations like this,
we can add new pieces
to improve the model.
So astronomers working
with the geocentric model
did this by adding smaller cycles
within the planets'
orbits around the Earth.
Adding these cycles did help
match the geocentric model
to the observations,
but there were many of
these cycles required,
and there wasn't a good explanation
for why these cycles existed.
And there wasn't very
much reasoning for them,
and they made the model very complicated,
and not particularly useful.
Let's pause and talk a
little bit about motion,
specifically apparent versus actual.
Imagine you're sitting in a car,
and driving through a forest.
To your perspective, as
you look out the window,
the trees seem to be whizzing by,
but trees, of course,
are rooted to the ground.
It's actually you that are moving
relative to the surface of the Earth.
This is the difference between
apparent and actual motion.
So back to our geocentric model.
Another way to explain some of the issues
with a model like the geocentric model,
besides adding evermore
complicated features to it,
is to in fact, just come
up with a new model.
And this is what astronomers did.
The new model that was proposed
to replace the geocentric model
was the heliocentric model.
In this model, the Earth
and all the other planets
actually revolve around the sun.
Helio means sun.
This heliocentric model
didn't need complicated
and unexplained cycles
to explain the way the other
planets moved across the sky.
It was an expected outcome
of the planets' orbits.
Now you may be wondering,
in this model, the sun is stationary.
So why does it seem to be
moving across the Earth's sky each day?
This is actually also easily explained,
because the motion of the sun in the sky
is not actual motion,
it is apparent motion.
Not only is the Earth
revolving around the sun,
revolving means orbiting,
but the Earth is also
spinning on its own axis.
And so as the surface of the Earth
moves with its spinning motion,
it makes it appear as if the
sun is moving across the sky.
The spinning of the Earth
actually explains why celestial objects
appear to rise and set
over the course of a day,
while the revolution, or orbit,
around the sun explains
the motion of those objects
over the course of a year.
It's important to remember that
while the heliocentric model
does a better job of explaining
and predicting our solar system,
which is what we want models
to do, it is still a model,
and not a perfect recreation of reality.
For example, while the heliocentric model
considers the sun as stationary,
we know now that the sun
is actually just one star
of many billions orbiting
the center of our own galaxy.
And so the sun, along with
the rest of the solar system,
is in fact, moving.
To summarize, in this video,
we talked about how we can use models
to help us understand
what we see in the sky,
and Earth's place in space.
As we learn more,
we improve our models,
and we can develop new
ones that do a better job
of explaining our observations,
and predicting the world around us,
such as the change from a geocentric model
to a heliocentric model.
The Earth then is a planet
that orbits the sun,
like the other planets
of the solar system.
And the sun appears to
move across the sky,
because the Earth spins on its axis.
Thanks for watching,
and I hope you learned a
little bit of something.